while you might be letting your guard
down as things appear to be getting back
to normal it's important to still
protect yourself
and others thanks for joining us here at
six i'm denise valdis good evening i'm
brian loftis health officials say
vaccines are most effective when
everyone has received one and
we're not there quite yet sally jeremiah
joins us live from the newsroom
to explain the push to get vaccinated
and continue with testing
denise and brian the southern nevada
health district and vice dean of
clinical affairs for the kirk recording
school of medicine at unlvc for those
who still have not gotten vaccinated
it's very important they do so for their
safety even though the number of deaths
are dropping we still have to remember
last year we lost over 600 thousand
americans
we're a little over halfway so the you
know 40 some odd percent of people
in southern nevada who are over the age
of 12 who haven't been vaccinated we
still
think it's very important they do that
michael gardner at the kirkha korean
school of medicine at unlv says although
we are not seeing a huge jump in cases
what we are seeing is the positivity
rate in southern nevada rising
those testing positive those not
vaccinated
i reached out to the health district
they are monitoring the spread of delta
and other kova 19 variants
recent lab sequencing reports show the
delta variant is now predominant here
even the new delta variant that people
are very worried about and rightly so
if you've had particularly the pfizer or
modern vaccine the mrna vaccines
it seems to be 98 99
effective also there is not an increase
in hospital admissions
or to the icu i am worried about the
parts of the country
that for whatever reason have not
chosen to get the vaccine in large
numbers missouri is a classic example
garner says with vaccinations low in
that state there is an uptick of
hospitalizations and he hopes that
people see
and hear what is going on in other
states and do what is asked to prevent
it here
if you're not vaccinated you should be
worried about it it's
highly likely that we may need a booster
would that be
annually would that be every five years
we just don't know yet as for wearing
masks it is not recommended if you are
vaccinated
it is up to you but federal rules still
require them on planes buses and trains
regardless of vaccination status
reporting in the newsroom sally
caramillo 8 news now
and there are incentive programs out
there if you've received at least one
dose of the coronavirus vaccine
you'll be entered to win 5 million
dollars worth of prizes for instance you
can win
things like state park permits fishing
licenses and even cash
with a grand prize of a million dollars
so winners are going to be announced
every thursday that's going to start
july 8th through august 26th
the program is funded by the way through
the federal government and will be a
random anonymous drawing